peuple
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ses biens l'assiette
anglaise en direct du saint-james club
comme tous les samedis vous savez qu'il
y a les grands rendez vous de l'histoire
il ya le bicentenaire de la révolution
française il y a le 70e anniversaire de
l'armistice de 1918 il y aussi la 50e de
l'assiette c'est aujourd'hui
alors comme on dit merci pour votre
fidélité continuer quand même d'appeler
vos voisins ils ont peut être la chance
de voir la nouvelle coupe de cheveux de
tom parce que c'est pas rien comme c'est
la caméra une qui est vraiment très lent
a séduit thomas regardez ce que ça donne
on n'a pas l'habitude de le voir comme
ça j'ai vu une grande mèche comme moi
maintenant il échoue en brosse tout ça
pour vous dire qu'on va parler
l'actualité cette semaine encore on
commence par le 11 novembre vincent
gerard devrait être là pour nous en
parler mais il était bloqué par le
brouillard dans la région de limoges
mais voilà quand même une histoire qui
nous et qui nous raconte maintenant d'un
monument d'un monument aux morts de 14
qui ne sera jamais inauguré
c'est un petit village qui s'appelle le
gentioux et vous allez voir c'est dans
la creuse il une bonne raison qu hongbin
inauguré enfin plutôt une mauvaise
raison
et oui jean sioux petite commune de 300
âmes à tout pour célébrer dignement le
11 novembre
un monument aux morts sur la place du
village un défilé fourni avec autorité
et anciens combattants une gerbe
somptueuse et une minute de silence mais
sur le monument un enfant lève le poing
et maudit la guerre alors
il y avait eu une instruction très
officiel du ministère de la guerre à
l'époque en 1900
24 face à ça remonte tout de suite après
la guerre de 14-18 pour que ce monument
ne soit pas officiellement inauguré bon
mais depuis le temps on aurait pu
oublier tout ça et l'inaugurer
officiellement enfin monsieur le préfet
je vous rappelle qu'il ya trois ans mon
prédécesseur a été accompagné des
autorités militaires locales devant ce
monument aux morts et une gerbille a été
déposé alors monsieur le maire jusqu à
présent et jusqu'à preuve du contraire
il ne semble pas que l'état par ses
représentants traditionnels c'est dire
le corps préfectoral et jamais déposé la
gerbe directement sur le no more as
jamais directement
eh bien monsieur le préfet soixante-six
ans après à quoi rimerait une
inauguration officielle
il faudrait vraiment que l'on veuille
réparer quelque chose y at il quelque
chose à réparer eh bien oui on peut
parfois être un petit peu choqué que les
morts de gentioux ne soit pas honorées
comme tous les autres morts de france et
de navarre
c'est peut être dû à la tradition de la
commune monsieur le maire on a toujours
été très libre penseur agences ou pour
ne pas dire un peu provocateur il y a
qu'à écouter les enfants du village le
11 novembre les élèves n'ont pas déjoué
et oui il ya des oreilles qui doivent
siffler mais monsieur le maire a trouvé
un truc imparable pour enfin l'inaugurer
ce monument se ce qu'on aimerait
aujourd'hui c'est que le monument de
gentioux sont reconnus comme comme lieu
de mémoire
jack lang ministre la culture viennent
de classer le fouquet's à ce titre il a
insisté sur cette notion de lieu de
mémoire
je crois que le monument le monument de
gentioux relève de 7 de ce classement et
on aimerait donc ils sont inscrits au
registre supplémentaire des monuments
historiques à ce titre et on s'entraîne
déjà agence ue comme si l'événement
était pour demain mais oui on s'essaye
au lâcher de colombes
bon le volatile n'était pas en forme
hier mes frais me days déjà à l'idée de
la venue du ministre ça pour dire ce
qu'on veut mais maudite soit la guerre
c'est une belle expression de façon
générale on comprend pas tabou et où les
problèmes c'est parce que vous mangez
cros malheur guerre moi ce qui me ferait
plutôt c'est de ne pas le mettre sur
tous les monuments fo rappelle quand
même que cette guerre dont on parlait
depuis deux trois jours
ces neuf millions de morts et 70
millions de pauvres types qui sont
partis sous les deux rivaux quand tu
demandais pas tant
quand on a côtoyé l'horreur je crois qu
on veut la supprimer
donc maudit sur la guerre des six jours
que soient marquées maudite soit la
guerre sur chacun de ces monuments
alors hier sur les champs elysées y
avait des des gardes gallois des wild
cards mais y'avait pas de pas de poids
du noir jimmy n'a pas de poids du noir
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de tirailleurs
sénégalais je n'ai pas vu vous non plus
j'imagine mais moi non plus oui alors je
n'ai pas très bien compris donc je suis
allé à une exposition qui se tenait à
l'hôtel de la monnaie sur les yeux sur
les tirailleurs le nom sur la guerre de
14-18 en général un général il y avait
deux trois trucs sur les tirailleurs et
j'ai parlé avec des collégiens qui
visitait il connaissait les tirailleurs
pas tellement va voir d'accord
parmi les différents soldats que vous
voyez au fond vous avez un tirailleur
sénégalais oui il y était aussi alors
c'est quoi un tirailleur sénégalais
j'ai entendu parler de la guerre 14 18
mais toujours allemands américains
russes viennent d'apprendre à l'instant
que le sénégal avait participé à la
guerre
que j'ai appris que c'était une
appellation s'était pas seulement pour
les sénégalais nous pour toutes les
colonies ils viennent de toutes les
colonies d'afrique aura voyons ces
tireurs sénégalais comment les
voyez-vous est grand mais très minces
avec un turban avec un pantalon kaki
bofa c
[Musique]
vienne d'un pays très chaud donc pas
habitué à ce climat très rude car
l'hiver en 14 étaient très très rude
devait tracer dépaysé quand même
[Musique]
c'était en europe moi j'ai exactement
une chose que les soldats français
moi j'ai pas déplacé mais guérir m
[Musique]
il devait avoir des canétois des
cannibales en afrique a cité par les
soldats qui partent en france et est
sélectionnée pour justement pas qu'ils
se livrent des problèmes mais non même à
cette époque là il n'était pas par nos
mimines étions pas cannibale mais à
propos est ce qu'ils se sont bien battus
mm en première je pense que cette c'est
l'appétit du combat de la de vaincre qui
l'aurait inculquer dans leur tradition
qui est donné de si bons résultats
[Musique]
et oui cette histoire presque oublié en
france nous on ne la raconte encore en
afrique
le vieux bakoroba parle toujours des
tranchées de la neige et de ses copains
blanc et chaque fois qu'il voit une
boîtes de [ __ ]
il part d'un grand fou rire
des images qu'on voit pas souvent qu'on
voit pas assez souvent alors oui dans
les documents vous avez y avait moi j'ai
eu avec vous il ya un manque est
merveilleux il ya un vieux tirailleurs
qui mord ya un ou deux ans qui raconte
qu'on était arrivé à toulon les enfants
nous frotter les mains pour voir si cet
itinéraire dans la rue temps en temps
non peut-être cru maintenant ça se fait
peut-être pluie alors les tireurs ils
ont apporté aussi des mots ils ont
apporté d'abord le bonhomme au naturel
avec la chéchia rouge
et puis nous ont laissé un mot que le
mot [ __ ]
ah bon parce que c'était du bluff c'est
quoi alors le mot [ __ ] ses 100 donc
ses mots au lof de langue parlée au
sénégal qui veut tout simplement désigné
la couleur noire par exemple au sénégal
on ne dirait pas peut-être que bernard
appalaches a les cheveux [ __ ] par
contre il est probable dans le cas du
maire s'est pas complètement
c'était plutôt des arabes
oui mais le mot et des vertus 9 le
laisser me va comme un gant à la
prochaine fois que vincent grass l'autre
il le dit amicalement faut dire que la
famille la cité anglaise alors par deux
grandes familles l'autre grand
anniversaire c'est le 50e anniversaire
de l'assiette anglaise une des
meilleures chances de podium des
meilleures émissions du monde
on a rarement vu autant de talents
réunis au mètre carré que dans st james
où loeb le samedi entre à 13 heures 20
22 23 24 27 à dépend des jours et 14
heures deux trois quatre ou cinq ça
dépend de la publicité alors vous
n'étiez pas là au début vous lie à 50 en
définitive c'est ma stéphane et vous
êtes allé rechercher des archives
langues
oui grâce à bernard conflit on a
retrouvé quelque chose de tout à fait
bouleversant je dois manger magie l'une
des toutes premières émissions d'un
certain toutes les craintes jouera c'est
peut-être en 1938
depuis sap a beaucoup changé en fait
jusque là qui me quasiment la même 50e
le décor est le même de saint-james club
le sublime
et les recettes de l'émission sont
identiques donc pour fêter en même temps
le neuvième anniversaire de ma rubrique
si vous avez manqué le début j'ai tenu à
vous raconter les débuts de l'assiette
anglaise très bien elle documents des
archives exceptionnelles vous ne verrez
plus jamais ça j'espère ce sémillant
bambins qui dévalent les marches du
saint-james ce club est déjà un grand
professionnel de la télévision la 4 ans
et demi et sa belle bernard rapp et
comme tous les samedis
il a réuni ses petits camarades au bar
du saint james
[Musique]
bonjour c'est l'assiette anglaise en
direct du saint-james club autour de
bernard rapp
les membres fondateurs de l'émission le
délicieux vassan des rares philippe
aubert sans ses lunettes oisel brigitte
simonetta thierry est sont grands des
jantes laissant sa boucle d'oreille
françois bernheim dit le et bertrand
renard
né le 28 avril 1935 là dessus cinquante
années ont passé et les recettes de
l'émission n'ont pas changé s'il vous
plaît bonjour à tous et à cette anglaise
en direct les salles j'aime ce club et
on ferme sa gueule déplacer voilà
l'argent vous êtes l'eczéma micro ici tu
es fou dernière
vous savez qu'avec une image vaut mieux
qu'elle grandisse caucheteux pas qui
disait ça mais c'était vraiment bien
surtout la télévision car contrairement
aux apparences avec télévision peut
montrer des images
d'ailleurs je suis là regardez je parle
donc le monde de l'image et pour que
l'émission soit encore plus juteuses
il faut y ajouter quelques épices aux
références
l'assiette anglaise qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous ça représente des
sous ça présente des sous à la fin de
chaque mois et je remercie le producteur
parce que sans lui je mangerai les pâtes
aux tons tous les toutes les semaines
une passion c'est la quincaillerie mais
les vrais quincaillerie avec des trucs
au plafond tout ça j'ai une passion
[Musique]
j'avais plus bernard d'un pc les vagues
mélangez tous ces ingrédients et vous
obtenez un cocktail en niveau télé
cinéma et déjà le bon gros vieux bon
sens de bertrand renard vous avez
remarqué
on n'a pas pris une ride en définitive
non non non quasiment identique
aujourd'hui jeudi je tiens à préciser
tout de même que le petit bernard ap
nous a été gracieusement prêtée par l'
agence 20 sur un an et le petit robert
le petit robert paraît facile à trouver
mais parce que même frontière entre la
20 eme après non y avait 50 ans 151 et
merveilleuse une grande équipe et une
très très belle émission c'est une des
meilleures du monde ou alors on va
parler de ceux qui sont pas contents de
la maintenant on va parler de ces pour
la déprime il ya des gros des primes et
des gros dépressif qui sont des gens qui
s'occupent de faire voter les autres
c'est un métier il ne faut pas vous
abstenir manque depuis s'abstenir on
vous a parlé la semaine dernière on n'a
pas pu parce que la semaine dernière on
n'avait pas le droit
ils sont en train de perdre le moral ils
vont même peut-être connaître la déprime
et enfin je n'espère pas mais en tout
cas ils ont de bonnes raisons parce que
les chiffres de l'abstention n'arrête
pas d'augmenter alors je prends mon
petit papier élections législatives 86
22 % élections législatives 88,34
élections cantonales 88 et ça c'est
important parce que les cantonales c'est
très très proche de nous 53 %
d'abstention référendum 88 ans le 16 63%
et d'augmentation des votes blancs de 5%
à 10 12 % d'accord d'eau alors qu'est ce
qui se passe on perd notre sens civique
c'est nous qui coince on qui voudront
pas aller voter ou cédant titution
pardon qui sont mal adaptés ça fait de
la peine aux gens qui s'occupent de ça
en principe il faut en l'espèce d'appel
au secours disons le à votre micro
voilà et il faut dire une chose si
jamais une ville française le trophée du
civisme quand même les maires les
français qu'est ce qu'on fait là bas le
cic doc centre d'information civique et
très déprimé
la preuve
voter un mot qui sonne comme un mot
d'ordre mais un ordre auquel de moins en
moins de français obéissent et dans
l'immeuble discret et du centre
d'information civique
on s'arrache les cheveux pour que tout
le monde retourne à l'école le jour des
élections mais pour l'instant ça ne
marche pas n'a pas voté n'a pas voté
l'abstention est à la politique ce que
la non assistance aux personnes au rejet
était la société la règle c'est que à
partir du moment où un vote a eu lieu le
résultat quel qu'il soit aussi juste
soit il a une voix près devient la loi
de tous y compris de ceux qui n'ont pas
participé au scrutin
raison de plus pour aller voter mais à
propos pourquoi ne pas comptabiliser
aujourd'hui les votes blancs
le bulletin blanc c'est le bulletin de
celui qui ne trouve de satisfaction dans
aucune autre réponse c'est un mode c'est
une c'est un une
un mode d'expression de son opinion
autre raison à l'abstention le manque
d'explications n'a pas voté vous avez un
fossé qui se creuse de plus en plus et
qui s'élargit de plus en plus entre vous
classe politique et l'opinion publique
et ça c'est très grave est ce que ça
tient au fait si vous voulez que depuis
en public est transformé en voyeur et
par conséquent ils ne sont plus
concernés les politiques ont donc aussi
leurs responsabilités lorsqu'ils nous
pousse vers l'abstention le ps 172 le
rpr en 88 le droit de vote suggestions
s'en sert trop et c'est vrai qu'on a eu
le sentiment qu'on avait un petit peu
abusé mais il faut bien se rendre compte
que le droit de vote suze encore plus si
on ne s'en sert pas on s'abstient
également parce qu'on se désintéresse de
tout ce qui est collectif et ça se
vérifie partout dans le monde n'a pas
voté et si les français tout simplement
trouver leur bureau de vote trop poster
après tout s'occupe ton assez de celui
qui a fait l'effort d'aller voter
ça n'est pas si sûr pourquoi ne pas lui
proposer un petit plat chaud ou bien
alors le faire participer à une immense
loterie s'ils votent dans l'année un
voyage gratuit en nouvelle calédonie là
c'est sûr qu'il y aurait beaucoup mais
alors beaucoup moins d'abstention et que
tout le monde votre
alors et là c'est vrai et c'est vrai que
ceux qui viennent de conquérir le droit
de vote dont il utilise les algériens
par exemple ou d'autres encore blu ray
vote - là russe aux paroles justement
puisqu'on parle du vote blanc c'est
quand même surprenant que il ya 12 % des
gens qui ont voté blanc pour leurs
efforts et se déplacer et de dire mais
je suis pas d'accord la question qu'on
pourrait ça compte pas ouais il étudié
tout de même une d une grande démocratie
tout à côté de chez nous on a le vote
obligatoire c'est la belgique ça marche
c'est une démocratie ça marche très bien
ils sont obligés de voter est-ce qu'il
va falloir en arriver là aucun homme
politique n'a encore soulevé ça tourne à
tour la tension volatiles devenir belge
c'est la question une question qui est
posée par le belge bertrand a une autre
raison c'est que les politiques font
plus de politique c'est à dire qu'ils
réfléchissent plus ils se vendent comme
des savonnettes et la preuve c'est que
le référendum
la fiche entre le canada et d'autres
émissions pourriez dire ça comme ça sans
mettre les menottes aux poignets
incroyable la preuve la fiche la fameuse
affiche avec le collier de fleurs
le kanak c'est pas un kanak c'est un
mois de louper un nanti d'un
guadeloupéen alors c'est dire le sérieux
du message qui est passé mais votre
compte aussi c'est de vous entendre
gérard dupire aquos matin accueil qui
est mon invité jean pierre accoce vous
savez sans doute ce qui fait il fait
tous les dix ans tous les 12 ans je sais
pas un livre très important qui
s'appelle ces malades qui nous
gouvernent avec le docteur pierre and
chic alors c'est toujours extraordinaire
parce qu'on apprend des choses
terrifiantes c'est que les gens qui sont
les grands de ce monde qui sont aux
commandes
eh bien ils sont très très très malade
et là vous récidivez il ya georges bush
qui vient d'être élu président américain
on apprend on sait pas encore pour bush
on va s'occuper de ses bobos à partir de
la semaine prochaine
monabanq reagan était dans un c est
assez incroyable regarde mal commencé à
entrer en maladie l'année de son
accession au pouvoir c'est pas de points
pas de pot il l'a d'abord été blessé il
faut le dire dans un attentat c'est
terrible qu'il avait qu'il est qui a
provoqué chez lui une hémorragie
pulmonaire très important mais également
une très grosse montée des sondages
exactement il en a profité mais on a été
beaucoup plus discret dès 1982 dès sa
deuxième année sur sa première maladie
qui était une infection urinaire qui a
commencé à monter le monde américain n'a
pas entendu parler
83 année a été une année calme 84 a été
une année terrible et personnes en
amérique on en a entendu parler parce
qu'il a subi l'ablation de deux polypes
pendant à parler que d'un et le deuxième
polypes était déjà un polype cancéreux
modique
mais tout le temps oui il dormait tout
le temps parce qu'ils avaient des
allergies avoué qu'on lui donnait des
antihistaminiques easter cdg l'a ratée
qui s'était c'était la chanson douvres
art ouvrard n'était pas américain
malheureusement sinon les américains
auraient pu en tirèrent sans doute un
enseignement et aux allergies qu'on
donne des antihistaminiques les
antihistaminiques font dormir alors que
megan dorment chez hier dans l'est pas
dans les autres îles d'or devant lé
conseil restreint de sécurité c'était
plutôt embêtant et les gentils stupéfait
et ne comprenait pas
on disait le président est fatigué ou
alors ils désintéressent de la question
il était simplement sous médicaments et
les américains étaient comme tenait
informé de son état de santé il ya
constamment les bulletins qui sont
donnés mais on disait pas tous - non aux
états unis on dit beaucoup de choses et
on cache sous ce que l'on dit encore
plus de choses on a parlé de son cancer
du côlon on n'a pas dit qu'il a vécu
pendant une année
censé repérer parce qu'autrement ils
n'auraient jamais été réélu il analysé
cancer a déjà été détectés en 1984 il à
cacher au peuple américain
il s'est fait opérer dès la deuxième
partie d'elle dès le début de son
deuxième mandat
s'il avait dit au peuple américain et
qu'il était cancéreuse jamais le peuple
américain de lui redonner un deuxième
mandat mais la vraie question est est ce
que est ce que regan a été affecté dans
ses décisions politiques par ces
maladies c'est un seule vraie question
des films ne restez pas très important
non exactement on n'a pas tout le monde
est malade et un moment quelconque de sa
vie mais tout le monde n'a pas le
pouvoir de te vers la fin surtout vers
la fin alors le pour le problème c'est
de savoir si quelqu'un est en passe ou
pas de gouverneur quand il est malade
c'était cela notre notre interrogation
quand on a quand on juxtapose toutes les
maladies de reygades avec toutes les
phases de ces maladies et le drame de
l'irangate parce que c'est un véritable
drame pour les états unis où normalement
il aurait dû être inculpé quand on
juxtapose cette malle à ces maladies et
les différentes phases de l'irangate on
constate qu'à chaque fois qu'il a dû
prendre une décision grave
ils étaient soit à quelques heures d'une
interview d'une intervention
chirurgicale soit quelques heures qui
ont suivi médical il n'était visiblement
pas en état mais la visite de routine et
c'est ce qui est le plus surprenant que
les chefs d'état donc que j'aime les
gens qui nous gouvernent sont les plus
mal soignée du monde
et oui ils ont beaucoup de médecins
autour d'eux et pourtant ils sont très
mal soignée pourquoi ça se comprend
ils ont des médecins courtisans qui ne
leur dit jamais la vérité ce sont ce
qu'il préfère ce sont ceux qui
choisissent ce qui est une plus beau
c'était le plus beau et tu n'es jamais
malade tu es le plus grand était le plus
fort
c'est un langage qu'ils adorent et puis
les médecins que l'état leur donne dans
les aime dans les délais dans la
démocratie comme dans les autocraties
cela ne disent rien à personne sauf à
l'autorité dont ils dépendent en général
l'autorité militaire
le médecin gars de chez eux mêmes qu'ils
peuvent et les militaires par devoir se
taisent ils savent que le président les
malades mais ils n'en disent rien et
puis quand le président malade entre
dans une phase dramatique de sa maladie
et qu'il faut vraiment intervenir offert
un bien aux consultants extérieurs qui
sont en général les plus grands chefs
des grands spécialistes
grand spécialiste ou les grands médecins
du pays et quand cela intervienne et
qu'ils prennent en charge le malade
ils deviennent la cible des 2 autres
sortes de médecins qui jamais n'applique
convenablement les traitements post
opératoire ou poste ou post diagnostic
l'insecte vous vous dites ça à propos de
pompidou guide pompidou aurait pu vivre
quatre ans de plus après quatre ans de
plus si on avait simplement règle est
respectée par les annonces comme il le
fallait traitement formulées par les
palabres consulter livre incroyable
parce qu'on apprend énormément de choses
et cj c'est très troublant c'est même un
peu terrifiant juste on a très peu de
temps une dernière histoire
ce designer dont vous appelez je crois
le syndrome d'alençon expliquez-nous ce
que c'est le syndrome dans lens on est
quelque chose de terrifiant au temps de
la guerre de 14 justement fameux
anniversaire il y avait dans les sous
les ordres de nivelles à monsieur qui
s'appelait alençon qui était colonel et
que nivelles suivait en permanence
donc de nivelles ce général c'est
l'inversé ça et le général nivelle
demanda d'alençon de lui préparer un
plan d'attaqué 1917 c'était très
important d'alençon s'en foutait
complètement d'alençon était physique au
dernier degré la lancement était un
monsieur qui allait mourir quelques
semaines après cette charge qui lui fut
confiée
il s'est totalement moquer du sort des
gens qu'ils allaient envoyer les plans
de bataille qu'il adressait était
terrifiant ils envoyaient à la boucherie
des individus qui allait mourir et lui
s'en moquer parce qu'il savait lui aussi
qu'il allait mourir et lui connaissait
la date de sa mort mais rien ne leur
dites vous était quand ils continuèrent
à vue cela il était jeune officier en
quand il a vu cela il a demandé au
peuple américain il s'était dit que si
jamais un jour il avait une fonction
quelconque lui dirai tout au peuple
américain
quand il a pris le pouvoir quand il a
été élu en 1960 54 il est devenu que
cardiaque
il a fait un infarctus et il a annoncé
on peut précéder le premier c'est ce qui
nous fait un petit peu la formation
illégale toute la formation et bien oui
car elle est née à ce moment là parce
que à ce moment là le peuple a des goûts
américain découvert ce qu'était le
cholestérol est ce qui était
véritablement tous les méfaits de la fin
pour tout savoir s'est installé pendant
l'expo n'est ce pas ces nouveaux malades
puisqu'ils avaient déjà les malades qui
nous gouvernent
ses dents de vampire a causé du docteur
pierre rennes smic et séchez stoxx un
livre à lire absolument pour comprendre
ce qui se passe tout simplement autour
du tout cela vous recevez beaucoup de
courriers j'imagine de vos bouquets un
an oui un peu sur sûr cela énormément
même j'en saurai plus parce que la grève
va s'arrêter comme vous savez peut-être
alors c'est qu'on parle beaucoup des
facteurs des villas vaches en train de
faire une transition voulait peut-être
noté une orient de rien on parle
beaucoup des facteurs des villes mais
aussi des facteurs des chants et des
facteurs des chances et des gens qui
font des grandes tournées dans les
champs et les femmes dans les campagnes
et quand il ya un vieux facteurs il
connaît par coeur sa tournée les
costières jeunes qui doit le remplacer
je connais pas la tournée donc ils
perdent des heures des jours il sait
plus où il est il est perdu d'où l'idée
d'un responsable de tourner ça se passe
à landerneau d'une idée géniale il a mis
un petit appareil dans la voiture des
jeunes nouveaux facteurs et ça donne ce
reportage de l'ela djitli et daniel des
vies voilà sur la carte
l'itinéraire curieuse gauche c'est jean
yves cariou le nouveau facteur l'autre
c'est monsieur robert le big boss de la
distribution du courrier à landerneau
pour lui pas question de lâcher sont
novices comme ça dans la nature alors on
revient à zéro et tu sortiras du bureau
de poste
sa voix ne quittera pas le jeune facteur
et le guidera pendant toute sa tournée
répète dans l'amour et ensuite une autre
poche vous gardez votre droite un chemin
où il ya de l'herbe
ça monte toujours
banier gimenez d'un cran quand il ya des
tournées qui font 80 et quelques
kilomètres plus de 80 kilomètres c'est
pas toujours évident en deux jours de
voir l'itinéraire de se rappeler qui
donc logiquement maintenant il le
préposé a droit à un jour le doublure et
le lendemain on lui donne la kas est
donc le lendemain il doit pas se perdre
ça c'est en théorie mais en pratique
gdba cgt au croisement l'année au lieu
de dire et sur la sur la gauche puis à
droite donc je n'arrive plus à me
retrouver à construire reculent et 50
mètres et de reprendre sur la gauche
avant de revenir par ici est-ce que
c'est agréable d'avoir une cette voix
présente comme ça dans la voiture avec
vous est-ce que c'est agréable c'est
agaçant c'est pas très agréable mais
c'est le moyen le plus facile pour pour
s'en sortir
non c'est pas trop dévoiler mieux une
bonne musique mais c'est pas
oui c'est pas sérieux d'autant plus
qu'il n'ya pas foule pour assurer les
tournées perdu au fin fond de la
campagne
nous allons procéder à la vente du
quartier de la poussette c'est à dire la
distribution des pactes et en ville
alors je vous répondrais assez fort
qu'on vous entende
mais attention cette vente de tourner un
peu spécial elle est devenue avec le
temps plus un rituel qu'une vente car il
n'y a pas d'argent à la clé juste une
bonne tournée avec en prime un walkman
et une cassette il faut bien vivre avec
son temps
à chacun son calvaire
voilà vous êtes peut-être un peu surpris
qu'on vous ai pas encore parlé de la
visite officielle du prince de galles et
de son épouse lady diana est bien aussi
mais ça va pas tarder on va faire tout
de suite grâce à christine de mazières
parce que vous savez à peu près tout
cette visite officielle y en avait en
long et en large dans tous les journaux
télévisés et dans la presse magazine
dont nous parlera tout à l'heure son
aile temps philippe aubert en corée en
aura donc mais on aura peut-être un
verre à revoir
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils trouvent
quatre soirées de gala très importante
et que tout était bon pour y aller mais
ce qu'on pas pu y aller et alors on a
découvert plus tôt christine la matière
découvert un petit bonhomme dans le coin
7 qui lui vous donne l'occasion d'y
aller mais de façon particulière oui
mais moi je tiens tout de même à
préciser que certaines personnes ont eu
l'occasion d'assister à des dîners
mandat avec lady diana et le prince
charles
un petit peu devenu sur la péniche
participants c'était très simple ce
n'est pas nouveau riche on avait quoi on
avait foie gras langouste et sont aussi
très bien pas de petits légumes
non je n'ai pas de petits légumes ce qui
n'était pas très bon mais c'était un
moment tout à fait délicieux en charge
d'abord on parlait de vous maintenant
des bonnes nouvelles de votre jeu
surtout que j'ai une passion pour cha
j'allais trop je crois qu'il a beaucoup
de charme wyler semble du reste à jouer
le roi n'est pas parce qu'il aura plus
trop près alors d'accord des hommes
d'affaires qui n'ont pas autant de
chance que vos bernard ap
et bien christophe becker a trouvé une
solution pour ces hommes d'affaires qui
ont envie d'avoir un titre
pour vous asseoir ici à la rigueur vous
pouvez vous appeler
martha durant voire renard mais pour
monter dans cette calèche de rêve
mieux vaut être un prince ou une
princesse mais voilà ce n'est pas si
simple
le temps les fils de charcutier fortunés
épouser les duchesses dans la dèche est
révolu alors une solution un billet
d'avion pour 7 et la rencontre avec ces
curieux personnage de devenir un jour
par an au prince pour compte légalement
avec la justice allemande c'est à dire
sous forme d'adoption
ah bon nous on verra père adoptif qui
sera un angle et qui vous donnera la
possibilité d'avoir ce titre sur votre
pièce d'identité
légalement ne s'est pas remis dable non
plus question d'avoir besoin d'une
réelle ou d'un roi point oubliant moi je
lui fais sans forme de viager ou lors
sous forme de rente qui va payer au
futur père adoptif une entreprise très
très très sérieuse en fait et je peux
prétendre que je suis la seule personne
au monde qui le fait par ce principe là
voilà pourquoi nous n'avons pas non plus
10 par an au contraire j'en fais un
strict minimum mais avec des clients
sérieux
voici un homme avisé moi je vais faire
un jugement pour savoir bon si cette
personne n'a pas un casier judiciaire
si lille bonne famille ce que la
personne noble va pas non plus de lait
sans titre le compare au prince à
n'importe qui et pas gratuitement j'ai
six poèmes thibault devenir compte
conteuse bar au prince ça dépend un peu
les titres de la valeur de l'âge des
titres ce qu'ils ont représenté moyen
âge par exemple la baronne qu'apparaît
le crawl acquis et un titre napoléonien
bon approximativement faut la mettre 300
mille dollars qui font plus ou moins un
milliard de francs français le prix
d'une princesse
il faut mettre un peu plus ça peut
toucher dans les deux millions et demi
trop bien le front français soit le prix
d'un petit deux pièces à monaco et pour
vous je sais pas philanthrope non plus
quoi c'est à dire le client aux
remerciements impe et le voyage il me
fait envoyer son avion silane avion
privé
il m'emmène en vacances et quelquefois
bon il peut me donner je dirais un bon
carnet l'adresse bisseux ses enfants de
19 10
jean le snobisme oui c'est un fils aux
extraordinaires
d'accord on est d'accord 2000 c'est
extraordinaire mais pourquoi ça passe
par l'allemagne
parce que paraît-il que la noblesse
allemande la noblesse à plus fauchés du
monde d'europe acheter bah oui d'après
ce que dit ce jeune homme on peut
acheter en plus il est d'origine
allemande
il connaît bien la halle allemagne il a
déjà la bonne famille là bas donc un fan
concept un fonds de commerce inépuisable
et mais j'étais bien rachat de bear la
bernerie moi je sais pas ce que sont ces
genres de noblesse basse que je vous
rappelle au béret basque
vous savez qu avant pour être pour avoir
des titres nobiliaires il fallait quand
même conquérir cet ide veulent aller à
la guerre de l'épée a dans le sang alors
que maintenant avec un carnet de chèques
craque
combien noble c'est que ça génial comme
6 2 6 3 pour la whip stéphane cardon des
fans le présent sur ce plateau
je tiens à préciser que la noblesse a
demandé peut-être fait chier mais que la
noblesse d'antenne 2 aussi que s'il
était spectateur ça c'est à cause de la
grève déposé par sud est chez nous et ça
ne s'achète pas ça se gagne
non ça c'est pas par les matins des
grands prix littéraires avec dan hardy
le bon coup c'est là dit le goncourt
c'est qui celui de l'année dernière vous
vous souvenez de son nom cd tahar
bendjelloun si je me souviens non
c'était michel host c'est ce que tout le
monde a oublié d'ailleurs personne n'a
entendu parler ailleurs nous
effectivement on va pas parler marketing
pour le goncourt en parler vraiment
littérature dr ya une expérience
intéressante qui se passe à saint
nazaire un éditeur de saint nazaire sant
nazer vous savez c'est cette ville
industrielle à hull city navale qui
étaient détruites c'est pas vraiment un
lieu de villégiature et bien lui il a eu
l'idée de vendre sa ville
il a profité de sa connaissance des
écrivains étrangers il a mis la mairie
dans le coup il a décidé de créer une
maison des écrivains mais dans cette
maison des écrivains il y à un écrivain
étranger à la fois et régressant
meilleur on a été voir ce qui s'y
passait ça naze hervé par les étrangers
donc à travers la littérature saint
nazaire 2 novembre un écrivain à sa
table de travail
la tenuta match aller la pinta dans
l'encré au delà de lancre
dillon ce navire cathédrale de métal
flotte et leur qui fines lames vers
fondent les eaux grises
il est colombien il écrit sur la ville
qui l'a invité ville a été rasée les
crises de la construction navale ont
fait douter et nazairien de même il
fallait de nouveau ouvrir et la maison
des écrivains arrivait tout à fait bien
pour créer une vitrine qui permettait
d'ouvrir sa nazaire vers le large et
l'écrivain de son balcon commence déjà à
se raconter une histoire une espèce de
coïncidence sans importance nous attend
a atteint l'extrémité du pont sur le
canal et stevenson me soutenez toujours
très légèrement pape de la paume de sa
main avec la délicate aveugle une partie
lumineuse venait de la mer
l'après midi était ensoleillé et limpide
et comme un grand bateau qui lui ne
partira jamais la maison des écrivains
c'est cet appartement ouvert de partout
la ville y installer michael d'autres
écrivains ont précédé d'autres le
suivront les uns à l'est selon les
syndicats c'est les autres laissent de
outre revu qu'ils ont qu'ils ont avec
les les autres voies il y à un monde qui
leur appartient de notes auquel nous
n'avons pas pas c'est un lieu individuel
et secret entre eu lieu ouvert et
disponible dans chaque écrivain fait sa
maison et de là c'est la ville qui le
regardent autrement
l'italien giuseppe kanté a imaginé cette
histoire le vent amoureux d'une petite
grue à souffler en tempête pour amener
la petite grue dans ses bras mais la
petite grue incapable de marcher aussi
vite s'est effondré dans le grand port
et son arme a disparu dans le ciel en
laissant le vent inconsolés de vitrines
la maison des écrivains est devenu
miroir et nezha rien ont redécouvert
leur histoire leur vie quotidienne mais
également leur environnement la lumière
l'air l'eau le vent et les rêves
au point d'avoir elle même des idées
poétique et si les paquebots d'autrefois
transportait les rêves de saint nazaire
à l'autre bout du monde
ce sont tous ces écrivains d'ailleurs
qu'ils vont s'en charger désormais à la
détour par la presse matin avec à
philippe aubert oui c'est avant tout
respecter je ne sais quoi
j'étais en train de lire une bd c'est
une bd qui va sortir c'est étonnant à
regarder
c'est une bd en relief tadic les doigts
c'est thermoformé sa siècle et doit
faire c'est très pratique moi par
exemple si j'en ai mes lunettes
les versions des petites aubert qu'on
éviterait exactement et je peux
continuer à comprendre ce qu'il ya dans
la bd à tourner les pages et donc les
non voyants qui nous regarde ce qu'ils
sont nombreux
on suivra ainsi cette fois c'est un gros
plans communaux viennent ternir battu
roulers en herbe semaines à venir si
j'en mets mes lunettes donc c'est très
rigolo je vous en a fait une petite page
que vous devrez conclu avec votre doigt
regardez ce très étonnant c'est du
plastique sémou savent pas c'est que
c'est un tout petit peu en récupère et
lance un petit pour lire dans le métro
parce que vous voulez comprendre jusqu'à
la fin j'ai omis les pages encore je
passe un mensuel qui est un mensuel chic
et branchée qui s'appelle globe vous
connaissez glop glop salon journal alors
d'un globe où il ya quelque chose de
très étonnant ce mois ci d'un globe
c'est qu'il ya un papier assez longue
contre le film l'ours le seuil de
nombreux tournois et mais heureux
exactement il ya les deux oui c'est quoi
il ya les votes blancs que c'est un
milieu qui est donc allé cela il ya une
chose qui rarissime ans après sa
première fois je vois ça c'est con on a
dans l'article des choses assez gentille
le 6 mars quand même des petites phrases
par exemple les offrants auront à coeur
d'en avant les enfants les enfants ils
auront à coeur d'emmener leurs parents
admirer ce film d'une pureté
éclaboussante c'est un tout très
gentille 1,6 une perte éclaboussante
alors comme on fait souvent ils ont pris
un petit morceau la phrase je montre
bien que ce soit les pommes croire un
petit morceau la phrase qui est écrite
et l'ont sorti pour faire un petit saut
n'a pas l'un à terre en termes de presse
et ça devient les enfants auront à coeur
d'en mener leurs parents admirez ce film
d'une connerie éblouissante
ça c'est g extraordinaire c'était pureté
éclaboussante et c'est devenu favori ces
correcteurs qui s'est fait plaisir je
sais pas ou alors c'est un parti pris
pour attaquer un petit peu le film c'est
un honneur de globe qui est très jolie
parce qu'ils gagnent photo va pas la
montrer chez des enfants qui nous
regardent si leurs parents
photos de noël mamère et noël mamère
fait quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel
c'est que il parle du paf il fait plus
que ça il le montre c'est quand même
assez étonnant c'est voila voila et de
noël mamère delbecque les acquéreurs qui
est axé sur le continent dans le mode i
mate on va continuer à parler ma
meilleure si vous voulez bien parce que
si c'est pas noël mamère soit sait pas
exactement noël mamère mais c'est assez
ma mère quand même c'est mathilda may
mathilda may quête à ses somptueuses il
faut reconnaître c'est dans l'express
paris et j'en parle très volontiers
parce que c'est un numéro spécial sur un
peu la zoologie donc une belle poule
mathilde hamel à la une ça c'est un
phoque
incontestablement on voit bien un phoque
et quand vous tournez la page
ça c'est un pingouin mais oui c'est vrai
les aubert qui arrive à parler green
dacia se doit c'est fabuleux
je m'aime beaucoup je vous laisse vous
la signerais tout à l'heure on va
continuer à parler d'une chose très
importante bernard c'est l'actualité la
vraie actualité de la semaine
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure j'ai mais
le titre c'est cet homme vient de dîner
avec mathilda may quelle histoire
oui c'est moi vous de vous raconter la
fin du dîner et donc c'est l'événement
c'est évidemment la visite de charles et
diana paris visite de charles et diana
sur lequel on a dit beaucoup de choses
mais pas l'essentiel c'est dans quel
état ils sont arrivés et ce qu'ils on
était fatigué et comment ils sont
repartis comme ils sont revenus chez eux
au pays alors ça on peut le résumer très
facilement ce sont les trois derniers
numéros de matches que j'ai là et
simplement avec les unes on comprend
tout regardez vous avez bienvenue
charles et diana ils ne sont pas encore
arrivés en france ils sont reposés ils
sont souriants ils sont détendus et puis
ensuite vous avez le numéro deux matches
avec la princesse die la daille un peu
plus fou n'est quand même envoyé que
j'étais très fatigué de la le voyage les
puiser toutes ces visites c'est à gap
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé bien
ensuite à une de match la photo ils sont
revenus au pays là ils sont quand même
carrément des prises et il faut bien le
reconnaître c'est donc le couple qui
aurait fallu avec dans ses cales et il
ya des échanges de cadeaux qui se font
alors moi j'ai offert au prince charles
ma photo dans l'express paris est à
kylie minogue a cassé et lui m'a offert
quelque chose que je tiens à vous
montrer parce que c'est assez rare dans
la poche rien à faire ça ah oui alors
est ce que c'est un cheveu de diana
n'ont impressionné les bleus
à ce moment alors qu'est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est un poil d'ours et c'est
quoi un poil d'ours est évidemment un
poil du bonnet d'or square des c'est
rarissime c'est une pièce de collection
venez danser enfin charles mettre dans
de petites poches et ça vous fera beau
cadeau pour votre 50e anniversaire
vous ne les fait pas bernard on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à gré avec
vous quand même peut-être un jour dans
un hamac vous verrez vous y arrivent oh
oui shui
merci à tous merci de votre fidélité
depuis 50 numéros surtout vrai semaine
prochaine samedi 13h20 toujours là c'est
anglaise avec les mange du talent
formidable au mètre carré
[Musique]
mais